ça se passe que j'ai qu'est ce que t'en
fais pas je suis croire et c'est la
première fois que ça me fait ça a
beaucoup menti aux barbes
je veux dire ça fait deux trois jours là
je vois je vois qu'ils troublent
champenois s'est rien passé terrible il
fait chier en plus parce qu'un match il
ya un mec de chapeau melon et bottes de
cuir
j'aime bien venir s'y tenir colombo ce
ballet savent pas s'ils viennent jaffré
d'eric darques
j'aime bien frédéric aime bien sa
mission même chez pat je suis pas d'un
réalisme
je vois deux pouces et est ce que je
vois les éléphants roses où ça regarde
regarde vous voyez ça merci il ya deux
éléphants roses et derrière tu as des
iguanes géantes qui comptent des enfants
volés voyez d'ailleurs juste la regarder
de dinosaures bleus en train de
s'embrasser dans le mali les bleus clerc
thierry leininger demi douzaine d'îles
au bout si vous les voyez aussi embêtant
tous ont à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait quoi toi françois mon écoute
moi ça va bien j'ai fini là le troisième
tome de la série sur les langues
européennes est l'avenir de l'homme aux
hôtels qui marche bien j'ai fait maître
capello que tu as lu probablement encore
que tu lire avec plaisir parce que c'est
bien et puis je suis sur une série pour
la chaîne culturelle
je suis sur une série qui s'appelle un
peintre a dit l'ag qui est à une espèce
de construction sur un peintre et le
village dans lequel il est né et donc il
ya toute une espèce comme ça de
progression dialectique on voit se
rejoindre au fond la personnalité du gua
et la personne et du village et c'est
plus parlant de voir on cherche pas trop
la cible jeune à c'est plutôt tu fais
quoi thierry moysset sur suis retourné
dans la pub la haye était pas rester
dans la télé c'est vrai que je t'ai pas
mais après tu as essayé août a pas voulu
j'ai essayé mais après de mieux je sais
c'est pas été bien nous les aimons ça
c'était bien c'était pas un patron de
queens est était bien ouais j'ai monté
une petite agence là tout va il en est
et dans la pub red et budget un budget
c'est quoi voulez-vous les prêtes à
cuire 12 france ah oui je les ai vus
vous m'en direz des nouvelles réparties
rêver c'est pas mal je suis pas très
cool mais ça mange bien face à valence
est en train de me refaire le passé bien
de double jeu au moins c'est positif
au moins tu vois quelque chose de qui
parle aux gens si tu es bien le jeu tu
fais quoi je fais ma cassette là le
rebelle ouais une dédicace à vous en
veulent à la casse et quatre vitrines
bonne ambiance
la 6ème sa neuvième lundi gm c'est
l'orgueil va tout ça mange bien à lens
est content ouais ouais c'est pas double
jeu c'est sain type ans
moi ça me manque un petit pan j'ai pensé
j'y pense pour vous dire la même chose
que je veux qu'ils allaient vous avait
coulé cette édition à force de dire des
gros mots et de faire n'importe quoi
donc aujourd'hui avancer là vous
lamenter moi ça me revient dès fois par
bouffer
[Applaudissements]
mes pensées
bah oui on est ensuite on fait comment
chanter alors petit bonhomme ça très
bien bien maintenant ça me fans plus mer
où j'ai l'impression de vous faire pas
mal on attend plus que tu dis ça j'ai vu
de la chaîne puisque tu peux y ait des
restrictions budgétaires en 92 sa mère à
temps et tard hiatus est tout bêtement
budget vachement de madame sera
augmentée mois pas grave on à l'antenne
mange ce gâteau may aucun problème qui
rit tu vas tellement j'ai le temps
ghetto des bas-rhinois zen messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue aux folies bergères
pour tous les joueurs c'est le feu de
dieu avant ça fait cinq ans qu'il
faisait mieux avant 92 qu'il faisait
bien tu seras grand père et tu
continueras de faire ça à des enfants
mais damien besoins et nos folies
bergères vaut double jeu faut savoir
passer la main à être arrêté à quel âge
tu t'es fait les cheveux blonds voilà
qu'on a fait bah juste après double jeu
pauvre la part je pensais jugnot là
c'est bien bonne émission 1 était bien
quoi c'était pas l'histoire des pinces à
st ouais on se souviendra du venezuela
abbey par le plus le mois le plus le
moyen par exemple ce qui te plaît le
plus dans le cinéma sa bonne réponse
ouais c'est toi l'invité ce qui me plaît
le plus
hop moi qui me plaît le plus au cinéma
ça il ya un côté club med c'est à dire
qu'on a une feuille de service ou sait
ce qu'on doit faire tout organiser on
sait où on va manger on donne de
l'argent de poche ou pour dîner le soir
ça c'est très agréable et un côté comme
ça on est pris en charge
est ce qui te plaît le moins dans le
cinéma c'est la tante eux
enfin je peux le dire mais la plus
grande joie de ta carrière
qu'est-ce que de quoi qu'est-ce que la
plus rependue à ta carrière
bah c'est de continuer continuer à faire
ce métier
sa méthode toujours la plus grande
déception
c'est de ne pas avoir fait certains
films travaillé avec des grands
pourquoi mais qui sont disparus qui ont
disparu mais non non c'est vrai j'aurais
voulu il projet avec de funès avec
ventura tu es sont partis ça ça m'énerve
bonnes réponses
on y voit l intelligence en six taureaux
coup de frais coup de fric
j'ai réalisé des pubs pour le loto ouais
tu dois laisser gagner
non pas du tout mais comme c'est plutôt
bien payé la pub j'ai fait beaucoup de
pub pour l'auto là j'ai gagné au loto
la plus grosse perte assez
c'est les cheveux
[Musique]
ce que tu préfères en toi le regard se
voir il est vrai que tu détestes en toi
avant une tête qui est posée s'il n'y a
pas eu de coups il ya un double menton
d'avoir ta plus belle histoire d'amour
c'est vous là est la plus minable
ben c'est vous aussi peut-être plus sexy
en toi les bras
sur ce que tu préfères le sexe le bout
ce que tu quittes dégoût devant le sexe
l'époque
comme le poil tombe ah oui tu as bien
ferme je tiens bien encore tu regardes
des cassettes pornos aller d'une main
oui non ça m'est arrivé de 10 est la
dernière à pouvoir il ya deux trois ans
d'accord pour voir les choses comme ça
qui détaille top 5 c'est impressionnant
ça laisse rêveur
ah oui c'est le temps qu'ont bon qu'est
déjà fait l'amour à plusieurs n'ont
jamais à plus de 2 c'est une fois il ya
120 ans way et mais comment ça s'est
passé ou bien non je suis pour sa déjà
utilisé des instruments les démons ne le
pense à ça jamais non le truc qui me
tombait sous la main un verre une
bouteille un truc
tu as déjà eu des expériences sado-maso
n'ont jamais fait fouetter par exemple
jamais envie non non non non on m'a fait
mal dès fois sans le faire exprès
respect des droits et dans vingt corps
du doigt comment je préfère pas y penser
non mais franchement vous n'avez pas des
souvenirs plus intéressant que les
pinces à st faut pas se plaindre les
bras où est ce que je ne vous avais pas
quelque chose de plus élevé à
transmettre à vos petits-enfants
les pinces à saint cyr gloria lasso
banon pour ça ça va plus c'est mon ami
on a eu des grosses truites dans
l'émission mais elle elle était vraiment
bien 1 c'était un internaute non j'ai
pas pu y aller non plus je peux le coach
à me rappeler double j'ai aussi venus
mon ami oui tu me l'as déjà chanté
fatiguant avec sa douce mon ami
bienvenue aux folies berchère reculer
tu vas faire là venus si si si c'est
difficile d'oublier les si le fait pas
je vais le faire fait gaffe à 20 titrée
dit que j'ai chanté a cappella voilà mon
petit louis venu bénisse mon ami
c'est moi qui la saison
j'ai sérieusement devenu ce que j'avais
fait à temps aussi vous voulez mais il
n'a jamais fait un clip parfaitement
idiot bien sûr oui sa première
apparition la première apparition
publique s'était à l'âge de six ans non
oui si on peut appeler ça une apparition
en public c'est à dire que j'avais un
papa qui était absolument délirant ouais
ouais il te faisait chanter dans les
cafés oui il me faisait chanter dans les
cafés suriname et puis et avec des des
maracas et c'était tragique quoi c'est
vrai qu'il a essayé de te violer ton
père non non non il n'a pas essayé vrai
viol et non oui à quel âge ça non pas à
quel est au pardon
non
je devais avoir 7 ans quelque chose
comme ça ryan a aussi comme ça oui
ton premier mariage c'est vrai que
c'était des forces et tu as eu ton
premier enfant très très jeune à kenza à
15 ans onta mariée de force
oui c'est encore ton père n'a fait ça
non ça a été ma mère est là aujourd'hui
tu arrière grand mère dans oui oui
dis moi tu plutôt bien conservé quand
même pas une arrière grand mère moitié
la plus jolie arrière grand mère que
j'ai jamais vue oui oui et je suis n'a
rien amené absolument délirant c'est ce
qui s'est fait retirer alors
parce que maintenant c'est le moment
important tu as été marié dix fois on va
essayer 19 9 bat ici d'y voir clair
on va voir si tu veux bien aller en
piste
or le premier s'appelait guillermo
tejero c'est vraiment s'il te plaît quoi
s'il te plaît celle-là c'est lui là
oublient le parce que je suis malade
seulement voilà à me rappeler serge ans
de carrière oui oui on va s'assécher
trois accidents que j'adore
le deuxième c'est vrai alors je sais pas
c'est vrai qu'il s'appelait maurice que
c'était son intérêt de son imprésario
âge il a vécu avec ton pognon jusqu'à sa
mort j'en sais rien moi jamais je n'ai
jamais posé nue à bon non il était déjà
marié ouais et je ne savais pas oui oui
je le suis parce que j'ai trouvé un jour
un petit message de sa son épouse dans
sa veste alors le troisième c'était ton
coiffeur claude et c'est vrai qu'il a
surpris un jour avec un garçon oui ils
étaient très mignons ils dépeignent en
or le quatrième alors là par contre on y
arrive ça c'est le pire c'est jean
selles français celui-là on laisse jean
marcy mais dis moi c'est pas lui qui a
épousé pierrette le pen depuis non un
petit ange non il n'a pas épousé non
plus non non il lui a fait faire un
livre
il a fait un livre je crois et il a fait
poser nue
dans playboy le cinquième il s'appelle
ernesto c'est ça
c'est un chef ouais sa guitare in life
et j'ai bien amour tu le regret c'est le
seul que tu as l'air de regretter le
sixième il s'appelait daniel et c'est
vrai g8 et courir alors le septième sais
pas si c'est vrai il était oréades or et
garder les oreilles au frigo oui non
l'égard des pauvres zhéros mais c'était
une véritable massacre
on nous parle t il pas pts et danser
dans des courses de taureaux d'ailleurs
ces patchs et pas tenable
oui et le 8e et le 9e j'avoue que j'ai
pas d'information je t'écoute c'était
qui le 1,8 m c'était un c'était nicolas
nicolas
il ay l'abbé il a 24 ans et puis ça
marche très bien c'était formidable on
s'entendait très bien s'amuser bien
ouais on travaillait très bien et tout
ça mais un jour il m'a sorti qu'il
voulait des enfants
le neuvième c'était salvador 6 ha non
solvables c'est un gentil garçon qui est
venu avec d'avec - du mexique avec
lequel j'étais marié sept ans et puis il
est arrivé ici en france et puis les
femmes françaises merveilleuse mais il
ya un jour j'ai reçu un coup de fil me
disant alonso c'est madame gloria lasso
oui écoutez je vous aie on nous appelle
avec une boîte comme ça je vous appelle
parce que vous savez je suis très
malheureuse
ah ben oui est ce que je suis prêt à
écouter je suis l'ami de salvador à
gedinne quoi bouger je peut vous être
utile à quelque chose
ab non parce que je voulais savoir si
vous allez l'immense et avait voilà une
information jeudi voûte et vous me dites
que vous l'aimez beaucoup que vous êtes
très amoureuse
oui eh ben je vous les donne et je
prochaine téléphone et puis sa valeur
est arrivé le soir il a trouvé ses
valises à la porte et il m'a dit tu pars
en voyage non chérie c'est toi qui as
lorient est ce que le soir avant de
t'endormir tu tu t'endors en contenter
mari comme c'est ce que tu tues tu
repenses est fatiguant excusé le
messieurs dames 1 du match pénible ça ne
va pas nous faire et ritournelles toutes
les cinq minutes
1 on a les cassettes je crois que ça
s'est fini faut tourner la page je peux
pas tourner la page un bon coup j'en
peux plus aux français
j'y pense tout le temps envie mais ne
nous arrête de brailler dans un bistrot
penser à dutronc la haye avait quelque
chose de pas mal dans cette séquence il
parlait de van gogh
non c'est pas certains sont passés les
séries sur gorre vraiment si c'est pas
sympa cette séquence là avant des thèmes
notamment des trompes
non je n'ai pas fait à cause de double
non plus à voir
ce soir qui avec son bouquet de cactus
je te laisse avec les cactus
entier
[Musique]
tél
battu à dix ans 22 septembre
j'ai bu comme un homme normal en trois
siècles
pas mal quand les jeux du bois pour
trancher pour trois siècles et tu buvais
quoi particulièrement je n'irais pas
jusqu'à dire de tout mais pas du matin
au soir
toutes sortes de choix tu veux tout
savoir mais non c'est pas une recette
comme ça il n'y a pas de recette le
slinger par exemple aspect comment
slinger c'est du faux de la menthe
fraîche faut du cognac et puis du du
budget mais blanc turin et ça te glisse
parfaitement mon principe c'est un ouais
j'en seul bien autre chose
entre le whisky le champagne ouais enfin
c'est du passé tout ça j'ai déjà mémoire
rey s'était arrêté j'étais arrêté du
jour au lendemain et la seconde près en
ce sens en cure de thurso conjoncture
commencent en d1 tôt valence est une
irlande eire
ouais pourquoi parce que tu le supporte
très mal quatre mois après ce que tout
le monde tu admires au début du recul
quel courage il a quel volonté machin et
petit à petit quand tu commandes de
l'ôter jamais servi ouais tu aperçois de
terre d'un coup au milieu des gens je
peux avoir mais oui oh ça arrive
monsieur non mais après tu risques de
tomber dans un état plus ou moins je
veux pas dire dépressive ouais quand
même
tu payes la nôtre est avec quoi tavel et
le fois qu'elle explose et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ou non il était bien fait au
point de vue gamma gt j'ai battu les
records
ouais j'ai battu bohringer de lamentable
des niveaux gainsbourg non il était
ridicule
ridicule non mais j'ai si tu veux gérer
tout comme a fait james dean beauvais où
il fallait ouais j'étais enfant je sais
vous conviendrez comme ça où ça vaut le
prix n'est pas un centime combien par
jour le plus possible ça fait de l'effet
pour les autres oui parce qu'il ya une
vanne que t'as pas dû manquer de faire
quand tu tournes et van gogh de dû la
faire c'est théo et débats non ça fait
souvent celle là sur des faits d'autres
inventent de gog c'est un fait ouais van
gogh pas mal alors en fonction des théo
était bas je vais te faire une interview
bendaoud tpr est la plus grande joie de
ta carrière la plus grande joie de ma
carrière lorsque ces eu un gala
d'annuler je suis rentrée à 8 heures les
producteurs
la chambre d'hôtel mardi que les plus
grandes déceptions c'est d'essayer de se
masturber que les pieds nickelés
je n'y arrive pas ça prend du temps
effrayant les plus grands moments de ta
bille c'est maintenant et le pire moment
de ta vie pedia parce que tu dit ça
après et c'est françoise alors oui ce
que tu préfères chez françoise riou non
c'est un tout jeune avant ce que tu
détestes chez françoise ses côtés
paperasse un peu un comptable que moi un
que des capricornes quoi je ne rentrerai
pas dans l'avant moi qui croyais comme
avait parlé d'astrologie a missionné bon
mais vous pouvez chez ya des phrases que
tu dis comme ça des fois j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que tu en penses tu des
phrases définitives et tragique tu dis
entre guillemets j'aimerais tellement
avoir envie de quelque chose c'est à
dire quoi que le matin tu te lèves et tu
as envie de rien mais il s'est donné
déjà dans déjà j'ai envie de me lever
c'est déjà pas mal
beaucoup de gens résident en ville est
parmi nous élever mais il faut que
j'aille faire ceci ce nom je me lève et
c'est ça qui est terrible c'est que ben
ouais je je tourne tu vas au cinéma bien
sûr et puis par moment d'accord tu aimes
bien tu aimes bien comme tu sais pas
très bien ce que tu as tu dis par
exemple j'aime bien avoir mal aux dents
parce que - tu sais où tu as mal oui
c'est bizarre quand même non ah oui mais
ça sans nous rejoint et à un état où
tout va pas très bien et c'est insidieux
c'est sournois on ne sait pas exactement
edel ou parfois malades en détient scène
j'ai mal je sais où j'ai mal là tu es
content zoug pas mal je vais ravis chez
le dentiste viseur les et doit faire ce
jour-là - étudient aussi la vie en somme
c'est vraiment des aphorismes la vie
c'est faire semblant de pas être mort se
dire ques rien avant
ton canular le plus réussi à l'époque où
on mettait les chaussures aux côtés des
portes ça pourrait faire nettoyer
j'en voyais mon secrétaire acheter les
mêmes alors soit une taille en dessous
le butin c'était génial parce que les
mecs trouvait toujours une explication
ça doit être le chauffage par le
superman gonfler les pieds à l'époque il
y en a eu d'autres branches et tous dans
un journal citait le feu au journal et
ont tapé à la porte on disait au feu et
bien entendu la personne devait dormir
donc son premier réflexe était d'arriver
pieds nus ou en pyjama et 2
et celui qui a mal tourné bah il n'a pas
encore justement
bon on va jouer à un jeu idiot comme
d'habitude toute façon je vais te donner
des noms de gens comme ça un peu comme
le tir au pigeon d'argile je vais les
jeter en l'air et tu vas me dire ce que
tu en penses
juhasz qui par exemple bien n'en pense
que du bien ça va bien bien vis-à-vis de
moi bien godard vient bien chaud payet
revient tout le temps comme ça
bah écoute j'aime bien qu'auteur un mois
aussi en moins claude sautet
c'est la famille dray je ne peux que si
ces soirées chez drucker
comment est ce que au moins les
questions aura été idiote et antoine
chemise à fleurs antoine il a bien fait
de faire de la voile
ouais voilà françoise hardy quoi ben oui
non bien pas bien jacques lanzmann donc
sa survie way to d'artois la wii qui l'a
remis dans l'enceinte où il marche tout
seul
gainsbourg beck août je crois que là il
est absent pour un slogan et c'est le
drame le parrain bull vous étiez très
lié on en fait je vais pas faire le
genre sanglots c'était mal
c'était un ami des facettes
c'est un des rares d'ailleurs deux par
rapport à ce métier claude françois tu
es là connue mais je n'ai connu
maquiller gelé pas reconnu démaquiller
un jour il a débarqué en corse je me
suis demandé qu'est ce que ces textes
monsieur c'était lui c'était vrai
johnny hallyday bah oui mais lui sur un
pote on s'est connus on devait avoir jeu
14 en 13 ans à la trinité la grande
époque mais diminuer la trinité mail été
pareil
il n'a pas changé lui profondément non
mais autour oui puisque quand c'est mad
max hillerman max et puis enfin il celui
des trucs mais c'est un des rares qui
même s'ils se met au goût du jour il est
toujours là je voulais c'est un des
rares qui est une présence et c'est là
c'est la foi c'est là est ce que tu as
connu c'est là à séparer les flux
d'immigrés la caméra explore le temps
elle est venue elle est venue dîner
c'est huawei
elle adore le saucisson ouais
en parlant de ceux ci sont tu trouves
pas scandaleux les rumeurs qui ont couru
sur son compte
sheila est un homme ça c'était l'époque
où on se faisait pas opéré oui
maintenant il ya plus de rumeurs
je suis dauphin de la place dauphine et
la place blanche a mauvaise mine
g
les avions sont prêts
nous sommes là
les synthois
il
céret
c
les travestis vont se rase et les strip
teaseuses sont ravis
les traversins sont écrasés les amours
sans papiers
les synthois ah oui
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
ah oui
c'est vrai
c'est les boules c'est que hardy aller à
ses habitudes de moi dutronc j'ai pas pu
aller à l'enterrement de reste moi
c'était le même jour que celui de nagui
lionnel luca son et vincent perrot qui
étaient partis en bateau qui titre passé
qu'à celle de doubler je dirige tous les
samedis soirs à 22h30
c'est pas mal hein tous les samedis je
m'en passer une depuis depuis depuis la
fin du double aussi et je fais des bips
arraché moi avec ma femme du gardien
souvient françoise hardy quand elle
parlait de jacques c'est une bonne
émission une bonne émission
ouais je comprends pas qu'on soit ému
j'ai regardé samedi ça va
c'était faire deux enfants par un homme
n'était pas amoureux sachant pour se
sortir de son milieu
c'est vrai ça ouais c'est vrai je sais
pas si c'était pour se sortir de son
milieu consciemment je pense que tu es
plus inconscients comme je pense qu'elle
était très flatté de voir qu'elles
provoquaient des sentiments très forts
chez chez quelqu'un qui était d'un
milieu très différent du sien et ils ont
rompu en fait ton père et ta mère ils
ont été de se voir quand tu avais trois
ans
ensuite tu voyais et on perd trois fois
par an à peu près non ouais quelque
chose comme ça et il paraît que tu avais
pas le droit quand tu lui écrivait de
mettre ton nom sur les leds parce qu'ils
voulaient pas que les gens avec qui
visage oui c'est vrai c'est vrai parce
que mon père avait sa vie de son côté
c'était
une relation la relation à ma mère était
quand même clandestine et donc les
et ma soeur et moi nous étions des
enfants
clandestine j'ai pas d'autres et on perd
en fête a commencé à se vanter d'être
ton père quand tu es devenu célèbre
c'est un fait que c'est un fait que j'ai
su que qui ne se cachait plus d'être
d'être mon père le jour le jour j'étais
un petit peu connu et un jour tu as
appris que ton père était homosexuel
mais ça m'a rien ça m'a rien fait
particulier parce que je trouve que
chacun a ses seins ses penchants à sa
façon d'être
moi je samarie somme sinon je trouvais
ça plutôt amusé en fait ça me fait rire
quand tu étais petit et pas trop
d'argent avait une jupe et pis tu es tu
à user les semelles de ses chaussures
jusqu'à la corde
tu as tu regardes quête souvient de
cette époque n'est pas une période où
j'aime me souvenir à part que j'ai quand
même eu la chance d'avoir une maman qui
m'aimait beaucoup qui aimait beaucoup
ses enfants et donc ça c'est quand même
un grand privilège
par contre ta grand mère tu l'aimés pas
beaucoup j'avais une grand-mère très
particulière et on dirait aujourd'hui
qu'elle est et névrosée
extrêmement important je sais pas elle
était plutôt du genre hystéro alors elle
par contre n'avait pas beaucoup d'amour
et on ça elle était très nuisible pour
son entourage elle te parler des hommes
elle te disais que c'est tous des
[ __ ] ont préoccupés par la chose
oui c'était d'autrui à peu près face et
peut-être pas tout à fait ces mots là
mais c'était d'autant plus surprenante
qu'elle était mariée à un homme donc mon
grand père qui était dit le contraire de
ça était quelqu'un de tout à fait
j'avais je pense qu'elle a eu un
problème dans les spots et la com com
tous les hystériques n'était pas très
gentil avec toi il te disais que c'était
pas mal déjà tirer un gros ventre quand
on doit maintenant parce qu'elle me
faisait manger les lentilles des flashes
et c'est vrai qu'elle rend quinzaine de
balles comme ça pour te dire tu avais un
grand mais c'est vrai qu'ils avaient
quelque chose d'assez malsain chez ma
grand mère elle ne tarit pas de complexe
et finalement 1 mais complètement parce
que je sais pas il paraît que tu le
faisais plus enlever ton manteau que tu
voulais jamais de mettre en maillot
avouez quand même arriver à tout le
monde en quoi mais je pense que beaucoup
des problèmes que j'ai pu avoir et dont
j'ai forcément encore les séquelles
assez importante devienne du
déséquilibre très très fort de ma grande
pour évoquer ces années là je vais te
faire une interview vous où on va
prendre un certain nombre de gens de
l'époque oui et tu vas me dire ce que tu
en penses comment tu les as connu ce qui
s'est passé avec on va commencer face
touch
johnny hallyday ce que je peux dire sur
lui c'est qu'il a une espèce de fantasme
à mon sujet qui me fait douter de sa de
la santé de son esprit par moments parce
qu'il est persuadé que pendant qu'il
faisait son service militaire je lui
écrivais tout je lui écrivais tous les
jours pour l'encourager toujours ce que
je n'ai absolument jamais fait cette
fois qu'il me voit et on serait pas
souvent soient tous les dix ans à chaque
fois il me rappelle ce truc là
et à chaque fois je me dis mon dieu mais
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui se passe
quoi pourquoi il a su parce qu'il n'a
plus toute sa tête
non mais je pense et je pense qu'il doit
être un petit peu mytho ici que j'ai
envoyé une carte postale je ne sais pas
et alors il a transformé sa sylvie
vartan tu la connais comme j'avais
participé à musicorama à l'olympia et à
l'époque elle avait un très très gros
chagrin d'amour et ceux qui annonça je
ne dirais pas et
et j'avais été très bouleversée par par
son chagrin parce que c'est vraiment
c'était plus que des larmes quand
c'était presque des hurlements elle
voulait presque se suicider quoi c'est
qu'elle avait été bouleversé par sa donc
ça c'est mon premier souvenir
extrêmement marquant de sylvie qui
n'atteint monde l'a rendu immédiatement
extrêmement sympathique
c'est là que tu as défend toujours chez
la turquie dans toutes les interviews tu
dit du bien d'elle tulle m
le défend de toute manière je me sens
quand même un petit peu solidaires de
signer chez là dans la rue ont
finalement on a débuté ensemble on a
connu un petit peu la même aventure donc
sacré malgré soi des liens et c'est vrai
que ce que j'apprécie c'est le fait que
quel est qu'elle ait voulu évoluer et
qu'elle ait su évoluer en même temps si
le public n'a pas suivi vraiment autant
qu'il aurait dû c'est une autre affaire
mais j'ai beaucoup apprécié ça chez elle
et puis en même temps ce que j'aime chez
elle que sylvie a aussi c'est que là
elle a une pêche et un dynamisme
incroyable est que quoi qu'il arrive
même dans les moments vraiment
difficiles elle et elle reste positive
alors l'époque tab a un succès fou
il ya une chanson qui s'appelait all
over the world bizarrement et que j'ai
donc qui était une chanson en fait que
j'avais fait paroles et musique et que
j'ai enregistré en anglais et qui
bizarrement est un succès dans les pays
anglo saxons ouais enfin donc
l'australie nouvelle zélande afrique du
sud
là tu as rencontré mick jagger le rite a
dit que tu étais son idéal féminin mais
si jamais passé il n'y a pas il me la
passer j'ai lu ça dans ses interviews
oui mais jamais rien eu d'autre entre
vaud n'ont hélas
alors tu as déclaré au matin de paris ce
lundi matin de paris pendant les six
premiers mois avec dutronc c'était
formidable
et puis du jour au lendemain tout a
changé et qui m'a tout parent en pouvait
plus se voir que de jour sur 3 ou un
jour sur deux tu t'en souviens d'avoir
dit ça
je l'étais je ne me souviens pas du tout
de l'avoir dit mais je sais pas si c'est
possible que je les dis parce
qu'effectivement du jour au lendemain on
ne s'est plus vu qu'une fois par semaine
tous les quinze jours notre choses comme
ça ok maintenant voyez tous les combien
maintenant c'est une ou deux fois par
semaine ça va oui ça m'a et pourquoi ça
parce que tu crois que les hommes
changent quand ils se savent payés
non mais là c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il prépare un disque devant nous une
maison à la campagne pour pouvoir
travailler tranquille et seule raison là
où bien sûr bon toi tu étais très très
amoureuse de lui
il te traiter midinettes il te trouvais
trop amoureuse très joli très détaché
tracy ne sais pas c'est pas facile
pouvait-on pas moi ce qui me traitait de
midinette c'est parce que j'ai toujours
aimé des chansons sentimentales tu te
faire le bilan de votre relation
aujourd'hui
alors est ce que tu as dit tu veux moi
tu veux que je le fasse oui vazyvaza
limagnole moi ce travail
bah oui oui vas-y tu dis si je devais
faire le bilan de notre relation est
prête
gt gt plus souvent malheureuses
qu'heureuse as-tu le chercher oui mais
je pense que ce soit moi qui le dit
c'est moi comme j'ai pas dire ça surtout
ici
pourquoi ici on est tous les deux
oui non mais c'est vrai mais je crois
oui mais je crois que de toute manière
dans toute relation forte les les
les moments de bonheur sont plus en plus
rare que le reste c'est la vie c'est
comme ça je crois que le bonheur est
plus rare que des c'est pour ça qu'on
court après est ce que tu crois pas que
finalement ces moments de malheur ces
moments plus malheureux que les autres
disant est ce que tu crois pas c'est ça
qui fait ton talent bon je me suis
souvent posé la question que ce que
j'aurais préféré ce que j'aurais préféré
avoir une vie un tout petit peu plus
tranquille un tout petit peu plus
sereine avec celui simple dans mes
attirances donc rencontrer des gens plus
simples et plus faciles à vivre ou plus
facile plus facile à aimer il pas faire
de chansons je ne sais pas je peux pas
m'attendre à ça je n'en sais rien au
début vous avez vécu longtemps jeu
chacun chez soi
oui et je pense d'ailleurs maintenant
que c'est la meilleure c'est la
meilleure solution comme michel morange
gérard oury septembre à compter toujours
ça fait michel margot et gérard où il
vivait séparé que c'est très bien non
mais ça malheureusement c'est un fait
que la promiscuité le quotidien sai
mousse beaucoup les choses comme est
justement jacques est quelqu un qui sait
tout à fait se rendre absents main quand
il est là quoi là selon la firme
problèmes du quotidien avec se pose un
petit peu moins et toi ça te rappelle
pas un peu ta propre en france
finalement ça cette espèce de séparation
c'est pas quelque chose que tu
recherches je me fais une psychanalyse
tout une consultation
vous avez quand même décidé de vivre
ensemble finalement c'était sans doute
après la naissance de votre fils thomas
non ouais pour lui pour thomas oui oui
bien sûr bien sûr avant tout
ouais mais pour moi aussi enfin pour
tous là tu es devenu un peu popote quand
même non j'ai toujours été pour moi je
fais des études chez descartes aussi
efficace et de boules hard
ça c'était ma personne fatigue ça
mettront côté me fais rien je ne suis
pas un mec comme ça qui est une pépite
est une star et tout pile la retrouve en
train de faire des boeufs bruxelles et
tout à vapeur ça non c'est pas mauvais
c'est ce que ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle emmanuel berl dit théodore le
mari de mireille les piments qui bon que
je voyais assez souvent je n'ai jallet
ont passé quelques heures avec lui
l'après-midi combien il n'était pas là
il me mettait toujours en garde me
disait fais très attention
jacques dutronc et plus enfin est tombé
amoureux est tombé amoureux d'une star
et pas une femme de ménage a
ça va eh bien ils avaient à la faute
aurait raison parce que c'est en fait
moi qui me suis lassé femme de ménage
j'en ai marre maintenant je finissais ya
c'est fini tu fais du fin du surgelé
bien raison il est mort alors est ce que
comme disais pialat au sujet d'un autre
film que van gogh
tu crois que vous allez dire ensemble je
l'espère ouais parce que ça fait du bien
quand t'écoutes indices tulle et coûtent
des milliers de fois je veux dire non
mais lui ça m'énerve dutronc ce genre de
trucs dedans tu crois pas à tuer mme
anissa veut le rendre fou pipi les
siennes ils doivent se rendre folle
aussi non pas des personnalités très
fortes comme ça ça doit être dur non
mais non à cause de ce que je te dis
parce que bon il est pas tout le temps
là et puis même quand il est là il est
extrême c'est quelqu'un de très discret
et moi aussi sauf effectivement quand je
me suis entiché d'une chanson là je suis
pas discrète du tout parce que je la
mets très fort et est très souvent
j'avoue que ça c'est mon plus grand défi
sera de vous pardonner quand tu le vois
faire l'amour au cinéma avec une fille
ça te fait quoi
j'aime pas ah bon l'écouté de toute
manière je n'aime pas le voir au cinéma
déjà enfin la mère ander en dehors de
ces situations particulières
je n'aime pas le voir au cinéma voir à
l'écran ça se fait pas sa maîtresse à me
gêne beaucoup j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'ils jouent très très mal si jalouse
comme fille la jalousie c'est plus
quelque chose qu'on éprouve soit comme
savons par exemple si je sais qu'il va
tourner avec telle actrice que je trouve
moi absolument sublime
ça va me ça va me tourmenter je dirais
je sais que j'ai eu en été gâchée par
exemple par par serge gainsbourg qui
m'avait téléphoné pour me demander de
parler à jal d'un projet de film qui
l'avait lui serge et dans l'est pour
lequel il souhaitait comme acteur
jacques et charlotte rampling à l'époque
charlotte rampling pour moi c'était
vraiment la femme idéale dans toute sa
splendeur la femme fatale est vraiment
je me suis dit s'ils tournent avec alors
là je les manteaux absolument horrible
et comme je le trouvais lui plus
irrésistible que le mari de charlotte
rampling que je trouve pas présent j'ai
précisé que je trouve très bien c'est un
très bon j'ai vraiment ça m'a gâché ma
télécommande magic peut se dire je ne
sais pas fait mais je ne manifeste pas
ne se passe rien alors la maison vous
avez chacun bozouls un peu c'est vrai
que quand vous avez des choses
importantes à vous dire vous écrivez
fait des petits mots des fois oui moi
j'ai fait ça pendant très longtemps
parce que c'est quelqu'un qu'il est
difficile de parler et donc
comme seul recours de lui écrire des
lettres auxquelles d'ailleurs il me
répondait très peu mais bon elle va par
des parents très peu très dur c'est pas
qu'il soit dur c'est que c'est je pense
maintenant je crois que je peux dire ça
je pense qu'il a effectivement un
problème de communication
voilà tu as dit que tu es même côté
féminin d'un homme jaime l'ambiguïté
ouais ouais j'aime qu'une femme ne soit
pas féminine à 100% et j'aimerais canal
ne soient pas masqués
les virils viril ça te laisse froid et
schwarzenegger oui oui oui c'est dû à
ton père tu crois
à
peut-être je ne sais je ne sais pas
parce que j'ai pas bien connu mon père
jouer mais c'est peut-être dû à ma
propre ambiguïté si on est un petit peu
ambigu soi même on a besoin de ça aussi
chez l'autre chez eux mêmes tu veux tout
tu as dis toujours à bon compte
extérieur la beauté intérieure
ah bah oui ça diminue les chances
c'est pour ça qu'ils n'arrivent pas
grand chose pas grand monde car on va
faire une interview oui non oui ou par
non voilà faut éviter de dire oui ou non
le oui est ce que si tu me tromper
dutronc jacques tu lui dirai non
c'est le fait est ce que tu qui traite
ou pour le grand amour
la maison tout manar thomas il est grand
oui est-ce que tu préfère avoir des
rapports sexuels dans le noir dans la
pénombre ou en pleine lumière
comme si on appelait nombre dans la
pénombre
mais oui bien sûr est ce que tu aimes
faire l'amour ailleurs que dans un lit
pas trop vous n'ont pas trop vide
vraiment un développeur cette seule idée
revues pornos non ah bon sans jamais lui
plais girl par exemple non ouais tu
regardes des cassettes pornos ça m'est
arrivé à settat plus ça dépend ça dépend
des acteurs ah bon parce que tu
j est ce que tu peux tout faire si tu
aimes chose les trucs les plus terribles
tu veux dire tout ça si tu préfères les
plus sales sexuellement c'est là où tu
vas non non ben voilà c'est clair on le
sait est ce que tu es déjà allé dans un
peep show non continuer je me gare et
ses voix
est ce que tu as déjà utilisé des
instruments tu veux dire non je n'oblige
pas à dire vrai ils sont assurés n'ont
jamais mâché peut-être mais je n'ai pas
de souvenir récent des expériences
homosexuelles
oui avec 210 m
ayant sado-maso eux
oui telle expérience dienstag sec c'est
à dire tu rencontres un gars sont
immédiatement partis ensemble faire
l'amour comme ça à bruay pour tout ça ne
l'est pas encore
c'était pas encore une anti voile à
bruxelles à notre époque c'est un peu
délicat difficilement on croit que je
suis hp est assez rapide mais bon c'est
en vente dans la seconde place est pour
quelques jours quand vous aurez honte si
tu étais surprise je pars un soir
jacques rentrer à la maison il ouvre la
porte il va dans ta chambre te vois
qu'une fille tu aurais honte
il lui serait absolument enchanté je
refuse de lui accorder
c'est bien de ça jean reno tu t'en
souviens j'étais bien pigé que c'est
renault qui m'a donné l'idée d'être
belle enfin j'ai vu le train de vie du
mec les bagnoles et tous les gonzesses
et bk gilles il ya un créneau lin n y
avait personne à son enterrement à
renault il sait pourquoi on a ça parce
que tous ses potes qui sont tous
rebelles qui pourra être récupéré par le
système ils sont venus le lendemain
ouais
jet tours
les cheveux oui on fait est là les
flaques être tu as toujours temps en
poule beau tatoué sur l'épaule
bah oui c'est pour toujours oui tu
regrettes pas des jours quand tu prends
ta douce de voir ça sur l'épaule
non non tout content j'ai pas que ça en
plus t'as quoi c'est un aigle j'ai une
bonzesse qui couvent de massip a mal à
sa famille à tout le monde le litre de
lait alors tu es tu as dit en fait que
tu as changé ton look parce que tu
voyais des renault par tous c'est à dire
que tu dis par exemple que tu avais un
foulard rouge autour du cou
tu le mettait au poignet quinze jours
après au premier rang il avait quinze
mecs étaient tous là où je tourne et
c'est ça ouais nan c'est pas faux que
pour ça non mais c'est un peu agaçant ça
fait même d'identification quoi les mecs
pour prouver qui tu es mais ils
s'habillaient comme toi j'ai vraiment
moi-même j'étais une caricature où je
sais pas si c'était eux ou moi soit les
mecs vous voyez dans la rue régale
l'habiller comme renault autour s'est
donné du mal pour être star maintenant
que tu espères tu as l'air de vivre
assez mal de célébrité 90 où je sais pas
tu dis quand je vais au méga star par
exemple je garde mon casque de moto le
plus longtemps possible sur la tuer
j'aime pas les endroits publics et le
monde autour tu as dit je serai plus à
l'aise finalement si je chantais à
l'abri des oreilles un peu comme ça je
serais plus plus tranquille quoi à
l'abri des bravo voilà bruit de l'argent
et des oreilles
le journaliste qui posait des questions
l ai dit ce mot gêne pas de chanter puis
que vous dise deviennent des vos
chansons deviennent d un produit vous
même vous soyez pour une consommation
consommation et à de maintes fasse
partie de l'industrie comme du
capitalisme tout ça je suis dit que
peut-être quelque part au fond mon
subconscient
j'aurais préféré doit vivre dans un pays
totalitaire et chanter mes chansons dans
à l'ombre d'une cave à l'abri des
oreilles de la milice de la milice qui
leur permettaient pas pour l'heure que
si le pen et élèves ce chiffre est dans
un pays totalitaire
alors on a fait une expérience en tard
me papa toi mais tu ont saisi en terme
'b tun l'ambiance de la bohème
tu vas voir voici costard de stars n'ont
pas fui cherchez quoi madame le concert
de renault il passe ici fontaine saint
michel c'est la mer
la mère elle m'a pris
souvient un mari de trop qui naissent en
direct
c'est un super mec ces mecs là c'est
parce limites ouais c'était quoi de voir
en vrai voilà je suis va jouer parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé
beaucoup ça fait de la peine de le voir
dans un creux de la vague aujourd'hui
coucou malraux beaucoup avancer vraiment
chiche et j'ai vraiment les boules parce
que [ __ ] n'ont pas semblé trop
respecté parce que c'est trop fort mais
aussi qui pensent que brûler lui a piqué
un peu tous ses fans
ça fait passer sur l'eau j'ai jamais
compris comment les gens sont sans
compas côté c'est ce ce genre de musique
il sape et ici on s'en fout de bruel
croit pourtant c'est pas des albums ses
albums il en a vendu 8
qu'est ce que ça veut dire monter un
chanson française c'est que moi j'ai un
chien et sa foule lâchement pour le
vérifier j'achète mes voyages allemand
j'aimais ce foulard et sont pour toi à
toi je veux tout petit ouais je retire
parce que lorsque vous lui dites pas ce
qu'il est un creux de la vague que vous
l'aimez beaucoup et que vous allez
acheter son prochain album
toujours pas convaincu vous êtes le vrai
chanter un peu pour voir qu'est ce que
voulait jouir à vous de choisir ça alors
là c'est pas l'homme qui prend la mer
c'est la mer qui prend là ça vous
rappelle quelque chose c'est une petite
pièce pour lui et j'ai pas de porte avec
une carte bleue y prend tôt je suis très
content de vous rencontrer
bon je suis un fayot tu peux lui dire tu
ne sais plus qu'une mère maintenant mais
renault oui il y en a on se demande si
j'attends pensée ou en étranger
comprends bien vous voulez bien signer
sa pétition contre le réchauffement de
la planète intègre alors alors au venir
la maison un jour si c'est beaucoup
dormi ça marche pas du tout son album et
la faire une tournée dans le métro ou
les lui demander un autographe
si les crimes chanson sur tonton ça n'a
pas marché
on essaie d'avoir au moins trois
autographes aujourd'hui c'est dur avec
lui on dit trop un
et vous le faites travailler dur comme
ça tout le temps s'il reprend les
compères et son trône
il en est sans contredit on peut
prétendre
huawei
l'ong
je sais que tu aimes pas beaucoup rigolé
été saisis c'est palerme là j'étais mort
de rire
je viens à toi reste où tu es resté à
l'isle-sur-sorgue plante des arbres
surtout ne retourne pas dans la bohème
c'est quand même pas drôle le chic je
peux retourner dans la rue les gens sont
sympas ils sont sympa de vivre qu'ils
proposent et dormir chez lui l'autre
qu'ils aient fait une barre de liant de
la part de l nova qu'est-ce qu'on écoute
corti
et pas la gravité a pas de corps type
c'est dur pour ça mais il y avait du
monde à l'enterrement il était aimé
quand est il un article que ses potes
presqu'autant que khaldoun
c'est marrant tu choisiras dole et on
n'aurait pas cru il est toujours là à
l'étonnant double jeu d'une belle
émission belge revient c'est quoi elle
avait rencontré sa vie retrouver sa
fille vous aviez dit des gros mots ou
droit du tout la pitié perdu c'était pas
perdre et du c'était une surprise comme
un sacré soirée tout court - non j'aime
bien
bon alors tu vois pas non on va la faire
rentrer alors johnny girard
alors
je porte en moi de mai mois de mai c'est
une fille ou un garçon garçon comme chez
des jeunes filles tu as le choix du roi
bravo alors est ce que tu es prête à
interviewer ta mère bon bah c'est bon tu
vas prendre ma place
et puis on va y aller ou pas d'accord
bravo est ce que rappelle le temps tu as
passé en avion combien on va voir en
italie où j'ai tout fait j'ai pas arrêté
et bon fond ça a été toute ma vie
pendant 30 ans quoi où c'était pour ton
père ou pour moi enfin pour le travail
ou pour toi et je me souviens d'une fois
je m'en souviens que émotions je sais
que à chaque fois tu me disais toujours
appareil qui misait alors maman quand
est-ce que tu arrives et j'avais ou du
travail beaucoup difficultés et caetera
et bon finalement j'arrivais et c'était
quand est-ce que tu pars et je me
souviens savais que je vais partir et un
jour taliko l'américaine c'est en dehors
de rome et un jour je suis mon parti
était arrivé et puis tu m'as vu
et puis je suis parti le lendemain et
puis des années après pleurer encore
alors tu sais j'ai lu comme ça par
hasard ton petit cahier comme ça
s'apprend niveau je le dis tu avais un
tout petit journal de bord quoi et puis
j'ai vu on fait un plaisir soit qu'elles
étaient parties qu'elles étaient restées
mais ce soit les partis et j'ai pleuré
quoi
tracé de l'absence de son père que tu as
souffert mais quand je t'ai dit à maman
je passerai à la casserole
ouais c'est vrai un jour je vais à rome
toujours comme ça toujours entre deux
avions entre 6 motocyclette ont reçu
plus et puis j'arrive à rendre piano
opus arrive à rome et puis je sonne à la
maison personne répond alors ça prend
quand même et puis j'attends j'attends
je sens que ça et je vois qui s'ouvre et
elle me regarde
j'ai tout compris tu avais plus les
mêmes vieux voilà alors je me souviens
je suis reparti le lendemain toujours eu
et je me souviens quand j'ai décollé de
rome je le faisais tellement de fois et
là j'ai quitté vraiment ram
définitivement parce que vu que je ne
vais plus à tromper avant on était très
amis
donc je n'ai avant que c'était vraiment
pour toi à partir du moment où tu as
besoin de moi je savais que tu étais
toujours bien je serai toujours mais
mais je me suis dit bon bah ça là je
suis passé ou rendent les oubliettes et
j'ai décollé je me rappelle j'ai dit
collet je me suis arraché dans le temps
et j'ai dit non de dieu et je suis parti
je suivais bas c'est pour moi je polype
du tout parce que tu meures tout le
temps
non mais bon on est content quand a
manqué beaucoup perdu
oui je les poches c'est elle qui m'a pas
banquier passe clairement je sais pas ce
que c'était parce que je n'avais jamais
mais toi qui va payer les intérêts des
autres alors bruno tu veux un café merci
donc ça va je pense à un truc là martin
quand il s'était classé que tout le
monde croyait que tsonga
tout le monde croit que c'est pour de
vrai n'empêche je veux dire un truc
qu'on a hyper bien bouffer enterrement
de martin y avait un solide client
formidable
n'empêche que j'ai vu l'école des fans
la semaine dernière il s'en tire très
bien arthur c'est bien c'est bien que
les gens qui avec les mots si si c'est
bien ça donc c'est un concept voix qui
tient bien notre cook double jeu je ne
peux rien dire les gosses ils mettent
pas diplômé de 10% seridi pour évoluer à
moi tout va se mettre là je l'aimais
beaucoup qui martin auger merde sur moi
j'aime bien arthur martin
[Musique]
c'est jacques martin et qui se sont tous
fait plus ou moins violet ils ont tous
été victimes d'attouchements des images
terribles
alex harvey le lightning alors là c'est
fini là je peux plus faire une école des
fans les maires vont ramasser leurs
progénitures et nsa paradis a refusé de
témoigner mais en a gros sur la patate a
dit pas mais ça s'est passé beaucoup
plus tard high tech retarder le plus
possible vous me voulez mon fonds de
commerce la dent mais tout le monde que
les bâtis rassure toi tu essayes dans
dix mois
je le trouvais dans le courrier et d'un
va téléphoner pour savoir pourquoi tu te
lèves et tu te rends compte que c'est
juste la semaine où il ya des articles
comme ça qui me fait ça c'est pas de ma
faute c'est que de témoignages spontanés
pour avoir cédé témoignages spontanés
je vais couper les moyens de recommencer
petit voyou bien cherché à cacher habite
dans la tendance des dix mois non quand
même là bon c'est vrai que l acte à une
certaine sérénité au mieux un par un ce
serait il à bidias vrai nom mais par
exemple quand à fena ils ont toujours
plus
éreinté fermenté film que tes émissions
quant à la nage est une seule critique
et cesser de maths ont fait du mal quand
même
oui ça fait beaucoup ça fait ça fait
beaucoup de peine mais c'est pas très
important
et puis dans notre métier il faut avoir
la peau comme du cuir
ouais sinon il vaut mieux pas le faire
parce qu'on est appelée à souffrir toute
sa vie c'est là que n'importe qui dans
cette profession a le droit de dire lui
cet art hagard lui c'est hans état
misérable c'est ses sous ça fait partie
implicitement du contrat même dans la
rue des fois ne te mets mes liste
s'arrête je lui ai rien fait je fais ma
gymnastique ce matin et le mec il a
baissé la glace il m'a dit sale con il
appartient
il a toutefois contraint connaître
alors tu connais ma cuillère mehdi
domina c'est moi qui l'ait fo juge a eu
avant moi
1 oui bon c'est un mec remarquable et
saufs connaît de le mettre dehors
avant je sais pourquoi
c'est un pédophile et expliquera ne veut
pas dire parce que je vais pas balancer
sur un copain dis moi et pas mal d
chacun il faut bien le dire aussi
comme tout le monde ce film n'a c'était
quoi parce qu'on parle toujours de na
s'était enrôlé un hold up à deux à
l'heure 1 e
ça n'est pas évident de faire rire avec
un sujet sur les gens âgés parce que les
gens ont peur des gens âgés
ça terrorise un peu les gens et puis je
sais pas c'était peut-être un peu naïve
dans la facture et je crois que ça n'a
pas été un succès loin de là ça m'a
coûté ma j'ai dû à rentrer à la télé
pour payer et ça t'a coûté aussi pas mal
d'années dans les supermarchés à faire
des signatures sinon c'était avant
c'était pour pouvoir faire le film j'ai
fait des signatures dans les
supermarchés comme on en fait tous
draine si tu n'en fais pas rejoindra
alors tu as bien 3 est assez
enrichissant
il a lu entre les dents qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est la même question
ouais je veux pas en parler
non je ne fais pas du mal comme ça
honteux fixant les objectifs très très
difficile de vouloir faire plein de
choses en même temps et fiable mais je
crois que c'est le secret de la vie et
du mal
non pas du tout il faut se fixer des
objectifs très haut très haut
et puis si on loupe attend pur commence
il ya pas de vent et ont cassé la gueule
alors finalement tu aurais pu être curé
archevêque archevêque actuelle chanteur
d'opéra t'aurais pu être journaliste
aurait pu être écrivain animateur télé
est ce que t'as pas l'impression fonds
d'avoir gâché un immense talent alors là
je viens on expliqué mais ce sera en
tête à tête si tu veux bien le processus
ça suffit ok d'accord bon allez on
lorsque le sujet et il peut ya intérêt
ok
vous et moi ça merde
jacques est en train de me [ __ ] tu
t'es où vas tu te casses comme ça tu me
fout en l'air dans l'émission et hors
antenne invité mon nom c'était question
c'est vraiment si c'est arrivé si tu me
connais tu sais bien que je pose déjà
bien en quoi pain et puis d'un seul coup
c'est c'est un piège dans des rites a
jamais vu mes émissions et non mais bon
les autres vous ne cessez différence
quand même je sais pas mais sur la même
chaîne
sur la même chaîne fait très en retard
sur les autres mais enfin la chose ah
bah voilà quoi question que je m'excuse
ok je m'excuse alors gentiment
ok je te prie de m'excuser non pas comme
ça ça s'est joué
je veux je te prie non simplement comme
tu le ferais un soir entre états et où
je dis à ta femme j'ai été retenu par la
télévision
j'étais retenu par la télévision excuse
moi avoue quand même que t'es pas facile
à vivre
là c'est normal sinon faire notre métier
c'est pour ça que tu as été mariée trois
fois non non non c'est pas comme ça que
j'ai été mariée trois fois c'est elle
qui l'envoie eu la patience
tu as dit les femmes sont de plus tant
d'ennemis harry c'est vrai ce sont
autant de tu n'as pas d'expérience ben
j'ai souffert humant favre tu as fait
d'armes entre mes blessures
c'est un regard françoise il séchait
alicia dans le dos rien
quelle horreur d'anciens combattants
terra nova beaucoup souffert quand même
oui ça se voit et en ce qui concerne ton
précédent divorce tu as dit le temps
passe mais je ne pardonne pas oui a
quelquefois je pardonne pas ouais bah
t'as pas le cas l'été celui d'avant là
le enfin ton dernier est différée
dernière séparation sadi ne tend pas du
médecin de écoute on en fait tout un
plat mais enfin je me suis mariée deux
fois c'est le moindre mal et céline tu
vas d'épouser ça c'est mon petit jardin
ah c'est vrai que tu l'a rencontrée sur
le plateau du monde est à vous oui ça
s'est passé comment le plus simplement
du monde
comment s'est rencontré sur un plateau à
tous les deux oui enfin on a bien fait
passer par ici on sait pas comment ça se
serait terminée corée ce qui se passe ce
soir
dis moi tu es dit céline m'a réconcilié
avec les femmes alors c'est vrai parce
qu'il est beau je suis bien parce
qu'elle m'a apporté beaucoup de choses
que je peux je l'avais jamais su tu dis
ça à chaque fois non mais non à chaque
fois s'édifie vous avez fait chaque fois
que je vais finir par passer pour
barclays ont débarqué en deux femmes
j'aimerais bien tu les revois tes ex
l'avenue où par exemple pu la revoir
elle est incontournable étudiants comme
partout
s'il ya une émission génie un génial
obligé non je vais demander ça
sa première partout quoi
bah oui ben voilà c'est un témoignage
conduisait était coincée du cul tout le
temps je crois oui il faut pas vous
étonner que le csa vous écoute hudler
mes petits-enfants
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque à l'époque mlcc
personnes à l'enterrement par contre
c'est vrai
tu es baronne c'est l'émoi est ce que tu
penses que ça te donne des droits ou des
devoirs ni l'un ni l'autre
ouais entre suivant ni l'heure ni dans
l'aristocratie ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui et l'aristocratie
curieusement sortie en fait surtout
vachement fort c'est comme si c'était de
minorités comme toutes les minorités
c'est un truc qui a vraiment des règles
un folklore et c'est extrêmement vivant
vous avez une devise si les turcs eh oui
c'est quoi c'est plus est en toi ô
messager je comprends c'est bien
vachement bon c'est une minorité
opprimée tu pensé arriver aujourd'hui je
pense à ceux qui t'ont premier mari
avait vu plusieurs premier mari ah bon
métier par des maris bague au doigt ou
d'umaru des marines ma fille parce que
ce que tu as épousé à l'église voilà à
vous à la mairie en chine oui car un
grand auteur de terre qui a écrit les
palmes de famille tout ça et aquitaine
aux autres femmes
nous on s'est quittés pour des raisons
qui ne regardent pas pourquoi
vérité pourquoi mais je tenais là pas
grand mal à tulle avait trempé dans la
vie on évolue oui d'abord jusque là
d'accord d'accord donc tu étais pas
commenter aujourd'hui comme d'été quand
avait 15 ans n'as tu fait un bout de
chemin avec quelqu'un de 15 ans habitant
19 ans que vous avez tarifs espace elie
j'en ai plusieurs des amis des gens qui
ont compté il n'ya pas que ceux avec qui
on s'est mariés et puis et bien après tu
changes et puis lui change ta puis la
mise en vie dont tu te sépare c'est pas
que forcément des histoires de cul
williams a vécu à côté desquels le
deuxième mari alors l'actuel avant le
séchage croit on dirait zsa zsa gabor
commencer je trouve simplement
ça va bien senti mentalement ça se passe
ça se passe au mieux mais je suis
toujours très réservé si tu veux sur le
sujet même si tu remarqueras l enfant je
vous donnais que trois avec le 2e marc
hé oui j'ai fait les trois enfants avec
le même mari ce qui est dans le
spectacle est assez étonnant dire j'ai
même événement c'est un événement fait
d'études défend quand même temps ses
trois enfants
mais ce qui me fait assez rire c'est que
chaque fois que j'ai interviewé par
quelqu'un du métier
non les gens à l'air de toi
extraordinaire qu'une femme fasse trois
enfants parce que toutes mes voisines de
palier etc
elles seront donc trois il ya rien
d'extraordinaire vous faire avoir trois
enfants
si ce n'est effectivement pour les gens
du showbiz donc je vais finir par croire
parce que attend maintenant les gens je
suis carrément la lapine du métier quoi
de faire une interview première fois est
prête
1 on est dans l'enfance dans les enfants
dans les mamans les papas dont ray péché
j'en ai tellement le premier que tu as
fait
avec une petite kaman a fallu revenir à
toi j'ai énormément jouer à touche pipi
c'était vachement des cousins et
cousines mais comme en ont décousu
parce que moi c'est que je les revoir
maintenant et que madoff c'est des
messieurs achement sérieux peut-être
coup je m'en souviens de toi
ces bombes est barbu je suis avec lui et
lui évidemment banon il s'en souvient
pièce qui me hérisse et qui s'en
souvient absolument portent les gens
résistent à leur mémoire mais je crois
que les enfants jouent moins en touche
puis non on jouait beaucoup de joie
patoijeux compute moi j'y joue tout le
temps quand j'étais petit je jouais
aussi bien souvent pas qu'ils en font de
maintenant moi je sais pas moi j'ai deux
filles sur pour le moins de son petit je
sais pas encore je te dirai savoir
quelques temps des seals et je vous le
dis je
sûrement pas mais surtout dans la
première boum première boum première
boum 12 13 ans qu'est ce que tu as fait
peuvent rouler des pelles et des ailes
ce soir je suis arrêté là huawei on
avait fait 13 à l'époque n'ont prononcé
mais non c'était des pétards et des
pétards des jeunes pendant trois ans un
peu plus vieux quand même moins 16 ans
dans cette branche et premiers flirts
c'était la première fleur c'était dans
une boum
il ya eu baisers profonds ou sympathie
oui mais le vrai de vrai baiser pour la
langue et la première fois que tu t'es
retrouvé toute nue avec un garçon a jeté
h quoi étonner et lui donc
il est surpris que ça se mette tout
droit sur tout ouais sous une douche à
lui l'arrivée sous la douche non c'était
ça a commencé en bas comme tous les
garçons qui aiment moi ça s'est mis en
route et ça m'a tellement étonné que du
coup ça m'a déconcentré et après je suis
plus donc on couchait pas si facilement
quand même à l'époque
ouais bah justement on y arrive première
expérience sexuelle mais avec
pénétration cette fois j'explique
clairement entre science qui ait pas
d'ambiguïté moi je sais pas j'ai une
victoire mais j'ai trois enfants il est
vrai
très très mignon fait j'étais très
amoureuse d'un garçon qui était très
amoureux de moi et on est restés
ensemble pendant cinq ans ah bah c'est à
dire mais tu garde un bon souvenir de
cette première phase annonce était
vraiment une paire des choix comme pour
pleins pleins d'anadys c'est la première
fois que tu dis quoi c'est ça c'est un
peu déçu et un peu d'issues convient pas
première expérience homosexuelle
l'expérience c'était l'époque je suis ta
génération il faut aller tout ici
c'était est où ici alors on a tout
essayé même la télé et alors je m'étais
dit et puis tu étais vraiment ringard
c'est avait pas une expérience
homosexuelle
moi ça me disait rien du tout mais je
lui disais puis ou mourir que d'être un
gala donc j'avais repéré une nana qui
était plus plus du gazon maudit tu
pouvais pas je m'étais dit bon va
falloir que je mal face à ne pas pas de
ça ne payait rien du tout il faut que
j'y aille quand même tu vois et puis j'y
suis allée malheur bourré comme un coing
et puis je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé
le seul truc c'est vraiment un matin
elle m'a dit tu ne t'es pas une affaire
ah ouais que tu as pu recommencer si tu
fais ça m'avait savait pas beaucoup plu
puis surtout que c'était pour l'avoir
fait toi moi je les fais je suis tu l'as
fait d'être enclenché troquier première
par tous ça c'était
ça c'est les jeunes voient maintenant
ils sont comme ça il faudrait point c
était dans le saisir ses grands parents
as tu crois pas si bien dire j'étais
chez un camarade camarade qui me dit
viens on va chez des amis boire un verre
l'app store ses chances des culottes
ces gens n'ont pas du tout genre c'était
un petit ami de l'époque et tout puis on
arrive dans cette boue mais on était
jeunes on avait 15 16 ans tu vois
arriver des matelas partout on était les
premiers mois j'ai pas vu le truc venir
tout un et puis au bout d'un moment bon
les gens commencent un peu tu as a
flirté tout ça mais bon tu te dis je me
suis dit bon toi je vois un peu fort
mais après tout la japonaise a comme on
dirait qu'on commençait à ceux dé saper
et au bout de deux heures tout on était
franchement à paulhe avec moi qui va
accrocher tous vos papilles tout et puis
là il m'a dit quand même attachement
coincé comme dana est toujours et là
j'ai dit ouais je cherche ma pensée
comme nana voilà et ancien effet nous a
regardé quand même non non non je suis
parti j'étais assez non non je te
promets un but non mais pourquoi je vois
là ok on continue deuxième parfumant
surtout qu'on puisse dire
bon maintenant on va faire une chose tu
vas te lever il va te diriger vers ce
fauteuil là bas et au moment où tu vas
t'asseoir sur le fauteuil dont rêve à te
poser une question par oui je vais par
là a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
champigneulles quelle est la personne
que vous détestez le plus
j'aime pas jacques martin est un gros
con parce que il est pas les gens être
intelligent qui n'a pas l'air gentil
elles sont choisies les filles de mon
pays leila une bonne émission mathieu
asselin et le monde à son mentor j'ai
jamais eu 5 dans l'émission n'était pas
bien il est élaboré ce mec mais
n'intervient qu'à ce que j'aime pas rien
mais es tu mourras seuls les petits et
inutile
très bien tu vois au moins auraient pas
fait que des heureux
non avait pincé l'enculé dans l'émission
spéciale j'ai commencé j'ai l'édition
qui démarre maman mais comprends je peux
pas venir maintenant j'ai l'émission qui
commence mais arrête avec ton infarctus
tu sais bien que le docteur choukroun il
a dit que c'était des douleurs
intercostales moment allô maman comment
avec qui je suis je suis de popeye mais
non maman pas popeck
popeye qui a d'autres schwarzenegger
ninon maman pas le docteur mais c'est
pas que je préfère passer la soirée avec
la victoire mais enfin maman ya aussi
une rico macias écoute mamans les papas
en dehors de tout ça et je t'en prie 1
me oui maman j en parlerai enrico je lui
en parlerai maman mais tu me vois en
train de lui demander pendant l'émission
si c'est ce qui est devenu maurice le
petit de madame benguigui à moi j'en
peux plus maman moi j'étais le pass
unigo
l'ensemble
alors à cette époque là est ce que tu
sentais que tu vivais les derniers temps
d'une période paisible oui oui
déjà c'était bien endommagée quoi c'est
à dire que tout était bouleversée
on était en pleine guerre quoi comme
comme ça se passe en ce moment même je
dois dire c'est comment ils bossent la
vie en ce moment où même dernièrement au
liban c'était comme ça par exemple on
avait des copains on se donnait
rendez-vous et on savait ans on faisait
les comptes le soir on savait pas si on
allait rentrer chez nous le soir à la
maison c'était aussi dramatique que cela
tu te poser des questions sur le désir
d'indépendance des algériens tu réagis
sait comment nous on réagisse et chacun
son intérêt c'est à dire qu'on était
français on était pour que l'algérie
reste française
surtout qu'on nous faisait des promesses
à l'époque on nous disait vous inquiétez
pas l'algérie sera française je vous ai
compris et tout c'est bon on va pas
revenir là dessus on va pas refaire
l'histoire
je trouve que bon c'est l'époque où
tombe au père a été assassiné il était
assassiné comment mon beau-père et
méritait pas d'être tué parce que
c'était un grand artiste et puis surtout
un homme bon quoi mériter pas mérité pas
il a été tué par un inconnu tout ça pour
parce qu'il était le représentant de la
communauté juive de constantine et que
des algériens en le tuant et il avait
signifié tous les juifs de constantine
et puis même aux pieds noirs de
constantine qu'il fallait partir quand
ils nous ont tués tonton raymond qui
était mon beau père il avait tué notre
cv notre les fondations mêmes de notre
communauté
les algériens étaient jaloux un petit
peu de la nationalité française des
juifs d'algérie qui datait de la fin du
siècle dernier avec le décret crémieux
c'est ça c'est quand le crémieux afld a
décrété que les juifs devaient être
français je comprends pas pourquoi il
n'a pas fait le même décret pour tous
les habitants de l'algérie et qu'après
on a dû subir les conséquences toute
façon tous les gens nous jalousent à
nous la communauté juive ce que ce soit
les
les gens d'extrême droite les fascistes
pouvait pas nous voir parce que il y en
a qui réussissent chez nous alors on dit
on généralise facilement évidemment
c'est les juifs qui réussissent mieux
que les autres et puis ceux qui ne
pouvaient pas nous voir il avait comme
prétexte disait oui évidemment ils sont
chouchoutés par le gouvernement français
ils sont plus français que l'école est
musulman alors ils nous ont divisés pour
que les autres règne à la mort de son
beau père tu jures d'épouser suzy la
mort de mon beau père a été mon premier
mariage avec susi
parce que de toute façon même si je
mettais pas marié avec suzy nos deux
familles étaient liés et comme j'étais
un peu l'aîné des enfants des deux
familles j'étais considéré un peu comme
le responsable
et alors là vous décidez tous de partir
vous avez pris la décision quand tout de
suite quand mon beau père a été tué le
temps de
l'enterrer j'étais obligé de partir
aussi demandé c'était la valise ou le
cercueil quoi c'était ça c'est de la
valise et le cercueil malheureusement
malheureusement on aurait pu éviter
l'indépendance de l'algérie s'est pas
seulement l'indépendance qu'on aurait pu
éviter mais au moins au moins les morts
moi ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
jusqu'à présent je comprendrais jamais
jusqu'à ma mort c'est que on il ya
toujours des tapis vert une fois que les
gens s'entretuent
je comprends pas qu'il ait pas déjà des
tapis vert avant que les gens sentent
revue les parties comment on est parti
sur le bateau studio guba de
philippeville
tu dis que dans le bateau les hommes se
cachait dans les coursives pour pleurer
c'est terrible cette traversée draoui
moi c'est moi l'image que j'ai c'est ma
grand mère ma grand mère qui était
vraiment déguisé parce que elle et elle
avait l'habitude d'être habillé en
indigènes quoique on était habillé là
bas et puis là les tabliers avec une
robe s'était elle ressemble à une vraie
française soit et
je la vois encore dans avec cette ce
tailleur de couleur marron foncé c'était
plus mal en même temps une autre femme a
été emportée quoi bon à rien emporter je
me rappelle que ma mère et ma belle-mère
ont dû retourner pour prendre des choses
précieuses ou de là bas mais quand on
est parti on on avait pas le temps de
rappeler de nos terres nous avons
emporté non même pas non non et c'est
sur le bateau que tu composes adieu mon
pays ouais tu veux pas nous faire un
petit bout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai quitté mon pays
j'ai quitté
ma maison
ma vie
matrix pays
se traînent sans raison
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté
mon soleil
j'ai quitté ma mère
leurs souvenirs se lève
bien après mon
na du soleil
soleil de mon pays perdu des villes
blanches que j'aime les défis que j'ai
jadis connue
j'ai guidé une amie
tous
je vois encore ses yeux
ses yeux
mouillez de pluie
deux gratuits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait partie tu pensais qu'il
reviendrait non non tu pensais que tu
reviendrais jamais étais jamais retourné
non il arrivé à marseille c'était
comment je me rappelle des montagnes
blanches les montagnes blanches et puis
surtout une chose qui m'avait consoler
c'est la couleur de la mer elle est
pareil qu'en algérie c'est vrai mais
c'était difficile au début
heureusement que l'accent chantant des
marseillais ça nous avait un petit peu
adouci notre notre rockeur notre c'était
dur parce qu'on venait de perdre des
êtres chers et très dur ce qu'il faut
que tu saches c'est que c'est toujours
dur jusqu'à maintenant
malgré la réussite et où est ce que je
supporte pas c'est le doute sur
l'authenticité la de l'attachement aux
racines parce que pour moi le d'oublier
ses racines ses six pu être un homme
quoi alors un jour il ya un miracle dans
ta vie c'est igor barrère qui fait un
cinq colonnes à la une il veut une
séquence sur les pieds noirs et il te
demande de jouer au milieu d'un anneau
il manque d'illustration sonore c'est
incroyable et on me filme à la mutualité
ont fini
le film et ça devait passer le vendredi
d'après donc une semaine après et igor
barrère viens boire un coup avec moi au
bar en face de la mutualité je me
rappellerai comme si c'était hier
et me dit voilà enrico tout va bien la
séquence est très bien passé mais c'est
la séquence qui sautent s'y est jamais
un événement important qu'on se fasse
dans la semaine alors tous les jours je
lisais le journal pour savoir pourvu que
les pas quelqu'un qui meurt pourvu
qu'ils aient pas associé du vin cela
pour que la séquence mal et je me
rappelle à huit heures du soir ce avant
même le générique c'est ma tête qu'on
voit à la télévision française à cinq
colonnes à la une il y avait toute la
famille réunie ma grand mère mon
grand-père toute la famille mon père ma
mère mes enfants n'étaient pas nés
évidemment encore c'était en scylla
c'est le succès parce que c'est immédiat
il ya des jeux c'est immédiat cas ce que
j'avais pris de métro avant d'aller chez
chez ma tante le pic bus pour voir
l'émission et quand l'émission était
passée en direct à 8h30 j'ai repris le
métro pour aller ailleurs et
je ne pouvais plus faire un pas dans la
rue et mon père a été qu'ils étaient
avec moi m'a dit ça y est mon fils qui
est une vedette et alors là il ya eu
tout un tas de tout un tas de chansons
qui ont été des triomphe absolu qui ont
marqué des gens par rapport au million
et j'aimerais que ça me ferait très
plaisir que tu nous on joue comme ça un
petit bout de chaque si tu veux si tu
veux alors fait paris tu m'as pris dans
tes bras on va faire le jukebox d'accord
allait bien
allez le lan d'élus communs d'enfants
perdus
j'étais 16
j'avais trop
toi paris tu m'as pris dans le témoin
le long des champs-elysées
les lumières
où
quand j'ai croisé les terrasses des
cafés elles m'ont tendu leurs fauteuils
sagem
bon
[Musique]
plus simple loin rue du four
j'ai fait danser pendant toute la nuit
fioul et une journée
à la rambarde en deux filles maintenant
les filles de mon pays ah oui
ah qu'elles sont jolies les coûts des
mots mon pays
mais quel jeu
ep
leïla
les millionnaires du dimanche soit en
attendant âneries qu il avait dit un
petit bout de chou
un élément attention sinon je vais dire
à qui les jolies baffie les
millionnaires du dimanche laisse le pain
sur la planche pour une chemise blanche
qui leur vin beaucoup mieux là il arrive
à la la la
alalalala
[Applaudissements]
mon coeur d'attaché au coeur d'attaché
c'est toi le toit de ma maison c'est toi
l'histoire de mes chansons c'est toi
mon chemin d'horizon sais pas
curd atteint
c'est quoi la voix de ma
c'est quoi
l'histoire de mes chansons c'est toi
ma vie
le paseo
[Musique]
enfant du pays
de tous pays d'endémie
je m'en vais
enfin
vous avez dans
bravo
intellectuel qui le voit la télé mada
intellectuelle
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est pas bon on va
la maison je vous montre ma cassette
j'ai fini le montage de rebelles de en
espagne le retour s'est pas avoir le
temps d'accord je vais pas l'emmener
voir mon film sur le prouver sur le ou
les dieux moi je l' ai vu que les vues
des mossi nom m'est venue moi je suis un
montage du dernier numéro de la peindre
un village j'ai un spécial véronèse qui
est non si on allait au faux nous attend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard youtube abonnez vous aimez faire
un peu ce bleu